you will not believe how much David  Tennant is being paid to reprise his  role as the doctor according to our  sources Disney plus is making a huge  investment into Doctor Who with an  undisclosed amount of money being pushed  to the BBC for international rights for  the property now a large portion of this  money is going to go into current  production costs meaning we're going to  get a massively massively better budget  for production quality  but Disney wanted a huge name to bridge  the gap between the current ERA of  Doctor Who and the new era moving  forward on Disney plus and they are  willing to pay big money for it this is  how much they're paying David Turner 5  million dollars  which isn't bad considering is only  going to be in three specials